okay but hold on a second why are you
holding purity at higher regard when
you're out here beating every chip so
the re the reason is because
men and women are different and that's
the thing like if a girl has had sex
with one person they're a virgin she has
an 80 chance of a happy marriage if she
slept with more than five it goes down
to 25 chance of 10 years having a happy
marriage so it's less valuable to a man
where like a dude the number one best is
if they're both virgins but if you take
that off the table like men's marital
happiness increases like from five to
eight partners where they're more happy
with the girl because we we bond more
during sex i mean that's why we have
terms like dickmatized
and can we be honest
women do want a man with sexual
experience let's just be honest that's
why it's different women do not want a
man especially when it's time to get to
that sexual place they don't want a man
that they've got to teach
they want they would prefer to be taught
by a man but a woman doesn't want a man
with no sex experience he wants to have
a man that doesn't know he's in his
bedroom